hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play gary darks my name is
markiplier and i'm about to die
huh it's docked up don't look at him
don't look at him and now we go until he
sees me I can crawl maybe I should walk
maybe I should run easy Oh
easy peasy lemon squeezy oh ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha hee ha ha they're coming
to take me away ha ha ha
to the funny farm my life is beautiful
all day long oh you don't remember the
rest of the words probably because of
how crazy I am
Prison West High suddenly did I go to
the prison I thought that's where I
thought downstairs where they didn't
want the prison's to go prisoners to go
I'm confessed
uh all right whatever whatever it don't
matter no framerate there we go that
looks spiky
that looks shiny is it dark
okie dokie
what's dis done a staircase was a big
room hello lady Oh what is that
ah baby are you doing Oh Oh baby your
legs go on for a sufficient distance
thank you thank you
what is this thing oh that's an eagle I
thought it was like some it looked like
a Slenderman type thing okay there we go
no still no torture
light on fire why why so many oh this is
I hate mannequins I really really hate
mannequins I don't want to see them I
don't want if I have a house I don't
want anything like a statue or a
mannequin to anywhere near me just it's
just not good it's just not good feel
okay look like it out of bones
ain't nothing it ain't nothing nothing
ah there we go
I heard something I did hear something
but I wasn't sure if it was in the game
or in my house someone who saw hammer
Hammer hammer saw I got the kitchen key
because prisoners need to eat too
apparently
hello baby alright more what that what
was that would you make me look at you
made me look at something you made me
look at something what was it why was it
why did you do that
why why why why why do you mess with me
game oh here we go batteries in jail I'm
not gonna playing but I'm just
questioning why this dark both of these
are like obscenely dark I think like
there's like there's different darkness
--is in certain mods like some are like
have super darkness activated and then
others do not uh anything else worth
anything new potato sacks hammer and a
saw okay that's it for that I got the
kitchen key now we can go to the kitchen
for whatever reason I don't know
all right that's all this then I'll wait
for a second
you go down there bound to be something
else in here shut up stop bitching your
life ain't that bad
suck it up okay no what's this
okay nothing okay I probably got to go
through the big doors to get to the
kitchen which makes sense
this whole construction makes lots of
sense if it's a prison then it would be
to get this many prisoners or fill this
place up well one you need more cells
into whatever awfully nice rug for a
prison I don't like it I don't like it I
don't like it I don't like this I like
this not at all
I like this negative I'm actually
running out of batteries which is
unfortunate considering how dark it is
around here okay these looks like
prisons
okay any batteries in here anything ah
shut up huddle up piss
nothing who's banging who be banging
loser
big loser nothing but a big old loser if
someone exploded all right once again I
am using up too much of my battle we
give me that anything in here battery
battery battery and I need battery
I need battery please this place looks
very old old in technology
I don't need morphine now I need battery
container I have a container now Wow who
cares there's a note here I never knew
the removing someone's head with a saw
could be such fun I actually got quite a
fright when the body gave a twitch after
the neck was completely severed though I
was soon laughing at my own foolishness
I'll need to remember to use a much
stronger blade next time though the saw
I was using was clearly not surgical
grade as it eventually embedded itself
halfway into the subjects spine and
broke off haha unfortunately my victim
wasn't dead by this point I panicked
haha I took the sledgehammer and brought
it down on his head one good swing and
some tearing was enough to break the
spine and sever the remaining skin I
know all of this sounds crazy and just
wrong even to me but well well I never
was much of a normal person to start
with and what did these worthless slabs
of meat ever do for me so I guess it
suits me just fine
oh well I'll run to the next victim
alright enough of that it's almost as if
I wrote it right it's almost as if I
wrote it bobbing on there was nothing
here anyway nothing besides that note
I'm going slow
all right okay
nothing bad happened nothing that bad
anyway
oz it's the kitchen no barely see
anything okay come on cannot use this
out of this way bunk maybe I could
weaken it ah that's finally the acid
because I got a container and if I go
get some acid then I'll be fine
because breaking it cuz weakening it
with acid first and then smashing it
with a hammer it sounds better than just
finding the key right I mean am i right
what okay never mind then never mind ah
here we go
kitchen maybe there we go ah yeah Oh
thought this looked like in shoddy shape
but what do we have here
Oh dust foggy daus is foggy okay looking
for a vat of acid whose some flowers got
me flowers oh here we go
this looks like something acidic Kedah
has an acid in a freaking kitchen
I don't remember the last time I cooked
with acid anything else in barrels got
you anything behind you no no sacks of
her haters fakey chests nothing nothing
a lot of nothing nothing absolutely dick
doodlee getting up here anything
anything up here huh
wha no nothing ooh ten box yeah that's
something okay I guess that's it all
right I'm out oh here nothing bad
happened so far
it's almost seems downright peaceful
this is
I just makes me more nervous it just
makes me nervous okay all right here we
go
all right put it on there okay it was da
ha boink
so smart Oh a hand pointing away
someone's telling me to go away
screw you guys I'm coming I'm coming in
I'm moving forward ok another bone
pointing towards the wall
ah come on Oh run to the door no joke
what else right oh all right it's not it
fix me seen the moves man I don't think
the Moose man's made an appearance yet
Oh turn off your flashlight you dumbass
oh the voice finally came back good
yogurt okay don't go well that's not the
right way to open the door uh-huh okay
Thomas
that's your name is it Thomas is that
you oh yeah thank God the door is locked
think you can find a way to open it you
don't get the Thomases a psycho maniac
just do it man just good man
I know you're not the brightest guy but
even you should know by now what's going
on
yeah come on okay okay if you're lucky
we might meet again after all it
wouldn't be any fun to kill my test
subjects oh right what about all those
murders you had I shall leave you now I
have to get back and finish something
I've been working on for you ah there's
the Moosman experiment what does it mean
by that this doesn't make any sense
I have to get out from the center fine
Nick I really hope still alive yeah I
don't think Nick wants anything to do
with you right now he seems kinda angry
look it's my it's my flashlight
permanently on oh I got it bugged or
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode so there's my revenge is
going to have to wait so thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye